what's better than walking into a
butcher shop and checking out the meat
selection today we're going to ask you
to build a blade that has been around
for thousands of years and in the hands
of butchers around the world that weapon
is the cleaver
now you're probably wondering what kind
of Steel you're going to be using to
make our Cleavers that's right here
you must Harvest your materials from
these high carbon steel meat hooks
they're all made of W1 steel and you can
use any method you choose to build your
blades a gentlemen keep your eyes on the
clock because you only have three hours
to complete your work and that time
starts now my name is Justin Workman 39
and I've been late smitten for roughly
four years the last three months I've
been going through chemo with the hopes
that I would Stave off the need for an
amputation of my right arm I hope it
sets an example that anybody that's
struggling no matter how bad it is you
can still power through it I have two
handles for the meat hooks so I'm just
gonna flatten them out and Forge all
these together
I leave my stack in the Forge until it
is yellow then I proceed as big blue for
help
all I have to do is not screw up the
heat treat and making sure I don't get
that Infamous Fireball in my already
hairless space
I'm praying I don't hear any Tings pops
Justin's got a nice Wharf in his blade
there
now I have to figure out how to fix this
problem this is why it's a good idea to
quench early right so that you can come
back and fix some problems
I still have a decent amount of mass in
it might as well just run the clock out
on the grinder
my name is DJ barrellgi I'm 41 years old
I'm coming from Oceanside California
the coolest knife I ever made was the
knife I forged cut my daughter's
umbilical cord when she was born my plan
is to grab the meat Hooks and cut off
the handles flatten those out into
pieces that I can stack forage weld
together they aren't as flat as I would
like them to be but I got to get this
going so I'm gonna weld them together
I decided to use big blue because I have
experience on a power hammer I've never
used the Press
I stretched out as much as I can and I'm
just trying to get it wide enough so I
use a Anvil and Hammer it by hand
he has been able to follow it widen it
out now I have to quench it
once now there you go oh
it was high but it wasn't bad pull it
out and uh I clamped it in a rice with a
couple pieces of angle iron just to keep
it straight
it looks pretty good
my name is Doug Siegel I'm from Mount
Laurel New Jersey I'm 33 years old
my uncle was a blacksmith so I got to
move some metal with him when I was
younger and I really enjoyed it you took
something rock hard like steel you heat
it up and it's like Play-Doh Cleaver is
going to take a lot of metal so I have
to make sure I have a nice big Billet so
I can stretch it out this way and that
way all I need to do is chop off the
front of this I can see if my welds are
good and from there I'll just start
forging
Luckily everything starts working out
and I make my way to seeing that I have
a perfectly good Billet now it's time to
make a knife
so I keep heating it up stretching it
out heating it up stretching it out dog
gives them the grinder and can he get
his blade up to temperature
it's going to take him two or three
minutes to get out of the temperature
exactly
I may have gotten a little bit too
confident I spent too much time on the
grinder now I got to get this build
heated up tell them when you got two
minutes on the clock
it's Do or Die
just put it in there audio one minute
quench gonna be a 30 seconds yeah yeah
oh come on oh no no no no no okay
he's in there all right finally leave it
in there five four three two one
gentlemen turn off your machines put
down your tools this round is over whoa
all right gentlemen congratulations the
three of you are moving forward into
round two of the competition where you
add handles to your blades turning them
to fully functioning Cleavers now
remember you only have two hours on the
clock for this competition and that time
starts now I'm going to address the
handle first so I decided to go with a
three-piece hidden tank by doing this it
allows me to cut out a couple steps
trying to pin the handle together
now I grab the Butcher Block and cut my
three pieces
after I approached the handle I'm now
going to be dealing with that major Warp
so I build a jig get it set up and heat
up the spine
it does not snap that's gonna have to do
I've got this thing pretty straight so
now we can move on to bigger and better
things
so the last thing I need to address is
that dlam in the center the only logical
solution that I can think of is grab the
welder fill the hole grind it clean
right now I feel this is the only option
to take finally we have solid steel
my plan for the handle is to cut two
identical scales and pin them together
I'm putting the holes in the Tang also I
went straight to the torch to just cut a
huge clearance hole that's what DJ's
doing is blowing pin holes drilling is
prettier but cutting with a torch is
faster I'm just trying to get it done
I'm pretty confident I feel like I'm
going to finish the blade and have
something to turn in
I'm going to put the handle on and
refine the shape of it
I had extra time so I'm trying to
decorate the handle I'm trying to make
something that has Soul it's something
you can't get at a store because I'm a
human being not a machine I'm at the
drill press and I purposely left my
handle unquenched I wanted that metal to
be a little bit softer so that I had a
better chance of drilling through it
[Music]
I got the holes drilled very easily so
now I just have to get the pieces of the
Butcher Block cut start getting them
assembled epoxied on and then start
shaping
right now I need to focus on the handle
being comfortable the blade has to
interact with the target but the handle
has to interact with the user so I want
to make sure I balance my time evenly
between those two things so now that I'm
in a good place with my handle but I
just want to refine that edge I want
that edge to be strong because it's
meant to chop five five four three two
one put down your blades put down your
tools this round is over
all right bladesmiths Welcome to our
strength test our Bone shot I'm gonna
take your Cleavers and smash through
these series of Bones what your blades
do to the bones is pretty much
irrelevant I want to see what the bones
are going to do to your blades all right
DJ you look excited I am that's all
right let's go do this
foreign
DJ nice job Edge held up just fine felt
comfortable in the hand a little bit
Square on the bottom but everything's
tight nicely done thank you all right
Doug you're up how you feeling feeling
pretty good how about it all right let's
do it
all right Doug you survived the bone
shop good job the biggest concern I have
is the thickness of your handle right
here a little bit short but there's no
gapping everything's tight and your Edge
is still sharp good job thank you
just in Europe how you feeling go to
town
all right Justin good job you survived I
was a little concerned with the gapping
right here at the shoulders but it held
up just fine you might have had a hole
in the side of your blade but there's
nothing wrong with your Edge good job
thank you
this is the sharpness test the meat and
vegetable slice now unlike the strength
test this is all about how well your
Cleavers cut the meat and vegetables all
right DJ your turn are you ready does a
one-legged duck swim in a circle uh
quack quack
let's do this
all right DJ's talking about your
Cleaver here there are sharp edges at
the top here but not as sharp in the
middle part when we cut the meat it
doesn't cut all the way through but
overall
it will cut thanks
all right Doug great name are you ready
absolutely ready to go
[Music]
thank you
all right Doug on the meat slice it
chopped but it's not a clean cut all the
way through now on the produce side it
pretty much cut everything overall sir
you're cleaver
we'll cut thanks just New York are you
ready for this let it rub all right
[Music]
Justin's talking about your Cleaver here
with the cuts over here plenty sharp
everything it cut through except for the
melon but overall sir you're Cleaver
you'll look up thank you
all right gentlemen you all met
parameters and you all tested well but
unfortunately only two of you will be
moving forward into round three of the
competition
the judges have made their decision and
the boy Smith not moving forward is
DJ and Doug's gonna tell you why DJ it
came down to the sharpness test your
blade has an obtuse Edge that coupled
with dulling from the strength test well
the potato getting hung up on it says it
all for that reason we're sending it
home no DJ fortunately your time and the
forces ended I'm gonna have to ask you
to please leave the floor all right
thanks for the opportunity well done
I would have liked to have done things
better I would have tried to slow down I
still got a lot to learn about making
knives but I had a good time